if you want to be honest
is that just a certain point yeah yeah
the thing is when you're going in that
and you go and lying i'm not even saying
you can do that but know what the end
game is know the consequences of what's
going to happen don't assume you can go
into the game line and think it's going
to come out like honest results you
can't that's like you planting a
strawberry seed and one in melons like
every girl you went to you had the same
game for huh huh no say that again every
girl you've went for was the same game
that you used to go for them what do you
mean by that i keep her buckled away
i say that personally because of
personal experience in um just growing
up in it i'm not going to dive too deep
into it however personal experience in
it yeah i know
long end game the head they can't worth
it g so you have a main chat chat up
line right well
every go i use the same kind of game i'm
coming on the same approach hi my name
is so and so i'm this kind of guy very
straightforward i'm going to be this way
listen i don't say all of that stuff but
you know
or do you adapt to the certain girl
would you adapt to the certain goal that
you're moving to now if you go for the
same type of girl
would you adapt to the girl if you're
the same girl then you still adapt
because you're adapting because she's
the same girl but i'm saying if you
change would you adapt i hear what
you're saying yeah you're not no that's
not an answer here what i'm saying no
question i'm asking your question
i can only say to the minus extent i
adapt by adapt do no no hear this the
adaptation yeah
is only parts when you're coming in with
somebody and you're compromising you're
not going to say the same when you
compromise or get with someone you're
not 100 the way you are when you're
single yes right right right then so do
you over the main part for the main part
i am myself i i don't change do you
exaggerate characters i don't why am i
changing for fema i keep her back and i
stay the same man that sounds so fake
bro
you know people like
okay people wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait you look you look you
know actually i'm lying you are acting
like they're in a honeymoon stage in a
relationship you know people are a
certain way when they first get into
relationship and they change to what
they naturally like bro you're on your
best behavior when at the start of
relationships not my best behavior it's
part of me lying about who i am bro
bro
your best one best trait ever a man's
best straight is his lies bro this man
take it
out i want to say that i don't mean like
lies like yo listen uh you're like weird
out there i'm talking about fabrication
um
elaboration the truth
listen
listen i am i am not
listening to the truth i'm not i'm not a
receptionist guys guys one time sorry
i'm not a receptionist i'm a
is valid however if you're coming in
with line know the results of line is
what's going to cost the results
headache bro are you single huh yeah
thank you very much so
yes so me lying me lying me lying and
him telling the truth none of it works
[Laughter]
that's kept why that's cap because
everything everything no but i hear what
you're saying
no because there's a process to things
not everything's gonna work out straight
away wherever you be honest that person
that you could have been with could have
been not to your not to stand this but
just doesn't correlate in the long run
so now you've got a break off you don't
know why i've um why things have broken
off right it couldn't have been from
lion could have been from something else
you're not compatible
thank you external internal there's bare
variables however if you're coming in
with lying no you're going to get lying
in attention
you've got to get lying results simple
so you've never lied huh no who said
that no one ever said that wait wait
wait wait wait i wanna i wanna hear
where his brain's at have you ever lied
no no no no you see what do you mean of
course then so he's never lied i
everyone has lied like that's what i
thought
what sets you in what sense in what
sense of life in what sense of life
there's no sense like you they're
speaking
what's the sense no i'm i'm you know
listen listen
i'm not saying that you have to have bad
intentions but i don't think everyone in
their whole entire life have been 100
honest like and that's just the truth
how you're saying oh sweet little lie or
like it's it's just a bit from the truth
either way like end of the day rather it
doesn't have to be cute like honesty is
not always cute like it can be tough and
the thing is
of me saying that that you've lied it's
not a thing against you i ever no one
tells the truth 100 of the time but
that's why i ask in what sense so
there's no sense there's no sense it's
either a lie or a truth that's what i'm
saying no but when i say in what sense
now i heard that point but we're not
saying what's saying how far huh yeah
how like what sort of lies are we saying
are we talking about right now
so the line is okay now so okay i was
right there
did that come out of my mouth so i'll
put that you she just said everyone's
allowed to lie and you just came back
and said okay lying to a certain extent
i'm saying hold on i just said life
time one time listen listen this man is
you're saying oh we're putting words in
your mouth i never said that i didn't
say it's okay to lie i said at some
point everyone has lied there's no man
that tells 100 like that tells the truth
100 of the time it doesn't mean you
can't try to tell the truth all the time
it means that at some point you've
fallen short so why so why are you lying
there
i just think i just think girls call her
kids we're humans we're humans like
there's no way okay so i just i i i
why do you lie
okay i have talalah i didn't say i
didn't lie
why do you lie the same way so many
people do it's escape it it's it's right
it's an escape out listen i didn't say i
didn't lie obviously that's why i said
we can't tell the truth 100 of the time
you can do your best to to be your best
the best version of yourself that
you will fall short of that at some
point at one point another you'll fall
short of that rather oh i just i just
put a dent in your car oh i'm not gonna
leave hey my number speaking of mike i'm
not my number is 0.678 i i'm in a rush
but here's my here's my number chat me
later so we can like fix whatever the
insurance
i didn't tell the truth because i could
have fessed up some people would do that
though i i didn't say that people won't
i said i know can we stick to the topic
but i'm saying to you you're willing to
lie about something as small as a card
then you're not willing to lie about it
i do have a question i do have a
question for everybody so
if you are in a relationship and
either you are you'll say your
significant other so the woman or the
man is making
a substantial amount of money taking
care of you you ain't gotta worry about
nothing
would you be okay
if they stepped out and would you still
be in that relationship so if if you're
if you're not the breadwinner if the
person that you're with is a breadwinner
and they have a substantial amount of
money and they're taking care of you and
you're just chilling and they step out
would you still be in that relationship
with them first of all i think that's
first of all i think that's unrealistic
for men because i don't think women
women are providing for men yes they
might be a substantial
there might be a substantial minority i
don't disagree with
i don't think i don't even think i could
realistically be in that situation to be
honest but uh but if i was if she was
provided for me
i would already have assumed that she
might step out because she's providing
for me do you understand and girls our
girls are really hypocrites like that
hugging me is real she understands so if
she's with a guy that's not doing
anything he's in the yard all the time
she'll tell her girls yeah he's always
in the house he's when he ain't doing
nothing he ain't getting up to anything
oh i'm here
doing my lawyer stuff or whatever blah
blah and he's not doing nothing well
she will step out with a lawyer or a
barista or whatever she will step out
would you be okay with that i would out
i would leave
but he's thinking he wouldn't never be
in that position
i couldn't put myself in that position
because i would already assume that yo
i'm a guy i don't know how females are
they're hypocrites so it's like why am i
going to put myself in a situation where
i'm not providing for her i would rather
provide for you can i ask you something
after that obviously i can't lie saying
once i bargain if a girl's wall
providing a tv plan she's allowed
oh that's a whole man situation in
itself but to play devil's advocate
let's say um you've met the thing in the
lab before you don't even know her her
status in it until you like but um
you're chatting a chapter and after you
are now doing the thing so you don't
know what it's like until you've gotten
a bit deeper in with her and now i don't
know whatever emotions or whatever
the relation that the dynamic is would
you still stay with her knowing that now
you've known because your your time's in
yeah would you still stay with him no
bro oh yes you're stepping out i'm gone
yeah i'm gone bro like think what's it
like obviously if she's if she's got
money if she's got money and she wants
to look after me and i'm doing my thing
and she's calm she's calm with it as you
said there's some women that are calm of
it and i don't disagree with it are you
gone or is she gone like
most likely she'll be gone because i
think what's it like wait wait hold on
because i want you to answer this most
girls before they leave a relationship
they've already decided they've left
everything yeah yeah yeah relationship
yeah right so yeah do you agree with
that it's true so you see you're see
you're lying then because you're staying
in a relationship
all right on that wait